do we really know what's on our plates
more than a year after the horsemeat
scandal any bees are pressing for
compulsory food labels on processed meat
the aim is to force members days to
indicate country of origin on all
products what we learned from the
horsemeat scandal was how complex the
food chain is and the European Union so
that in order to sort of I supposed to
deal with that complexity we need
country of origin labeling which would
make it easier to trace our foods before
the European People's Party mandatory
food labeling is not the solution dear
fellow flash scandalous bottom Papa
talked i speared of large i sling flash
declare porn often for a common and has
come on of mystery and the hair comfort
consignment phone flash for hidden and
easier ian art I love food and for
barajas for Toya catfish helium smitten
massive mepz voted in favor of food
labels and processed meat the next step
is to urge the Commission to make
labeling compulsory for members dates